Oh
such
I spent it
Oh
you just keep
you just keep me
it's a tremendous pleasure being here
with you today in Conway mall I'd like
to start with a question can a person be
perfect well speaking from personal
experience
yes as a child I was perfect I was
perfectly good at least outwardly
inwardly I had a lot of mischievous
thoughts I was perfectly smart I was
always at the top of my class this I
believed would ensure respect from
others as well as self high self regard
if I ever considered easing up something
would come along to underscore the
importance of being perfect for example
my sixth grade teacher mrs. Wilson
seated us around the room in i.q order
it was already the top I kid class in
the school but she didn't care for her
every point of IQ was incredibly
important the lower IQ children were not
allowed to wash the blackboard or clap
the erasers in the schoolyard or carry
the flag and the assembly take a note to
the school principal for her your score
summarized everything about your
intelligence and character how could you
not be affected by that
I was so perfect that I had to start
shrinking my world to maintain it in
grade school I was the best speller in
the school and they wanted to send me to
the Regional Championship spelling me I
said no the next year I was the best
student of French in the school and they
wanted to send me to a citywide
competition
I said no why would I put myself at risk
I was already perfect and I had to
curate that perfection now perhaps if
life were one large schoolroom it would
be okay to stay perfect trying to stay
perfect but life isn't like that it
changes radically and it begins to
reward taking on challenges seizing
opportunities and sticking with them my
charge today is seek to speak about a
vice or a virtue it's perfect
action ISM a vice or a virtue Pam's got
a friend and colleague surveyed adults
asking them to answer the following
question am i a perfectionist how would
you answer that on the survey many many
people said yes but there were two very
different kinds of yes so listen to this
am i a perfectionist one person said I
want to get it perfect the first time
every time my inner critic is constant
it is my judge my warden or in the same
vein another person said having built a
magnificent dam of perfection that is I
am perpetually plugging all the holes
it's tiring depleting it's about fear of
chaos and anxiety that what is is not
good enough and that I am not good
enough but now listen to this
this is a little bit different am i a
perfectionist this person says I do
believe it serves a purpose it got me
where I am today I am known for high
standards and excellent work why would I
ever give up this excellent tool hmm
so sometimes it sounds like a vise and
sometimes it sounds like a virtue what
does the research say the research says
there might be two different kinds of
perfectionism one kind of perfectionist
agrees with statements like this people
will probably think less of me if I make
a mistake if I do not do well all the
time
people won't respect me if I fail partly
it it is as bad as being a complete
failure but the other kind of
perfectionist
they say agrees with statements like
this I try to do my best and everything
I do I Drive myself rigorously to
achieve high standards I have a strong
need to strive for excellent
so this kind involves setting and
striving toward very high standards and
leader will ask if perfectionism is the
best word for that the first that
self-critical kind has many negative
consequences anxiety depression
compromised relationships but the second
kind striving for excellence can have
many positive consequences not only
higher achievement but greater life
satisfaction how do we understand where
that defensive self-critical part comes
from that idea that I I want to get
perfect the first time and every time as
opposed to the more inspiring striving
for high standards to understand this
let's look at my work on mindsets and
let's listen for the fixed
that's mandate for perfection in this
research I identify two kinds of
mindsets people can have about their
basic talents and abilities in a fixed
mindset people believe that their basic
attributes are well fixed the talents
abilities and personal qualities they
have now that's all they're ever going
to have and so they keep asking is what
I have enough and is it enough to make
me admirable is it enough to make me
worthy this is what they're always
wondering but other people have a growth
mindset they believe that their basic
talents abilities personal attributes
can be developed through effort learning
mentoring from others what they have now
is just a starting point now they don't
necessarily believe that everyone's the
same or that anyone can be Einstein but
they believe that everyone can grow and
develop let's look into these mindsets
to see exactly how they work first what
is the number one goal for people in the
different mindsets when we ask people
this question in school at work in their
relationships those with the fixed
mindset say that their number one goal
is to look and feel extremely
accomplished at all times but above all
never to feel dumb or inadequate
students say this I like school work
pets do
fix my zit say this I like school work
best when I could do it perfectly
without any mistakes but students in a
growth mindset so their number one goal
is learning the reason they do their
schoolwork is to learn new things they
say I like school work best when it
makes me think hard and it's much more
important for me to learn new things in
my classes than it is to get the best
grades guess what they get the best
grades because that outcome that badge
of honor that the fixed mindset students
want so desperately is achieved by the
growth mindset students because they
engage deeply and effectively in the
learning process grades outcomes are a
byproduct of engaging deeply and
effectively in a learning process we've
been doing a large study of fortune 500
companies and we hear the same exact
thing from the fortune 500 people the
more employees held a fixed mindset they
wanted to look the more they wanted to
look smart but not just smart smarter
than everyone else they said it's very
important to me to show that I am more
talented than others at work when
working in teams it is important to me
that I am the star of the team good bye
teamwork
it's what we call the culture of genius
and it's about looking and feeling smart
at all times and at all costs but those
were the growth mindset in the fortune
500 company said it's much more
important for me to learn things at work
that it is to get the highest accolades
they wanted to learn innovate
collaborate and those are going to be
the store performers remember how when I
was busy being perfect
I was also protecting myself protecting
myself from the spelling bee and the
French contest
I wanted to remain part of the culture
of genius and we looked at people in
relationships
those were the fixed mindset tell us I
want to be worshipped they want to
always be right
those were the growth mindset one their
partner to challenge them to grow when I
had a fixed mindset my worst fault was
always wanting to be right even I was
put off by the Glee the relish with
which I said I told you so
on the rare occasion I was wrong I look
for someone I look for someone or
something to blame anyone but me my
husband and I finally had to invent a
third party we named him Maurice and he
was the person we blamed for everything
so that we could get around that blame
game and start getting to the important
things let's talk about role models
they're supposed to be inspiring right
you see someone who succeeded in your
field who's like you and it should give
you confidence it should excite you if
you're a person with a fixed mindset
that wouldn't be right
people Jenny Burnett and her colleagues
showed in their research people with a
fixed mindset are demoralized by
successful role models they say oh
that's a different kind of person from
me I could never be like that that
comparison that gap where they don't see
the bridge is undermining to their
confidence but people in a growth
mindset are inspired by role models they
think that person has found a path I can
find a path to maybe I can even find
someone like that person to mentor me
and lead me along the way so this first
part says that they're in a fixed
mindset there's this constant issue of
proving that one is without full that
one is king or queen of the hill sounds
an awful lot like perfectionism doesn't
it second there is a question of effort
in a fixed mindset even effort may shout
imperfection inadequacy people in a fix
I said believe that if you have high
ability you shouldn't need effort and
that if you have to exert effort why
that means you don't have high ability
effort to them is only for the lesser
the imperfect beings the fixed mindset
students in our studies tell us to tell
the truth when I work hard at my
schoolwork it makes me feel like I'm not
very good at it but the students with a
growth mindset value effort and
appreciate its power to ignite our
abilities and help them grow they say
the harder you work at something the
better you'll be at it same thing with
the fortune 500 people the ones with the
fixed mindset devalued effort if you're
really good at something they agreed you
shouldn't have to work hard at it I
think this is the worst belief that
anyone could have everything important
and this is a sermon part everything
important in life requires huge amounts
of effort over long periods of time and
F if effort makes you feel inadequate
incompetent you're at a huge
disadvantage fascinating studies now
show the power of any little effort to
undermine the confidence of people in a
fixed mindset david nelly and his
colleagues did a series of fascinating
days where they gave people reading
passages and for some of them they made
it that feel more effortful for example
they made the font more difficult to
read or they made the sentences in the
passage they made the syntax a little
more complex every little thing that
increased the effort you needed
undermine the confidence of people with
a fixed mindset they rated themselves as
less competent and less good at
comprehending the passage every time
they had to apply more effort even when
effort was induced in the silly and
irrelevant ways since I wrote my book
mindset I get letters from people who
were once child prodigies many of them
have not finished University or found
meaningful work
they expected effortless achievement and
people promised it to them they said oh
you're so brilliant you'll be this
you'll be that so they sat there and
waited for that to happen but guess what
it doesn't work that way you actually
have to do something
also being talented became for them
something that others had to do being
talented became equated with not having
to work hard like other people when the
day finally arrived and it always does
that they did have to work hard they
weren't able to do it it made them feel
just the way they didn't want to
you now
not long ago I spoke to the top athletes
in a nearby country and they told me not
one of them had been number one as a
teenager the number ones were the
Naturals they coasted on their natural
effort natural ability and they were no
longer there but the people I was
speaking to the people who had been
number 4 or 9 or 16 they knew they had
to work hard to get where they wanted to
go and they did it they were now the
people going to the Olympics and the
World Championships now this idea of
effortless superiority or perfection is
prevalent in our two cultures your
former prime-minister
H H Asquith once described Oxford men
from his college as possessing quote the
tranquil consciousness of an effortless
superiority
and there is something rampant at my
university Stanford University called
duck syndrome
what is duck syndrome well you know how
Ducks appear to glide along the water FS
effortlessly but they're paddling madly
underneath that's Houston many Stanford
students are and many students at elite
institutions they look like they're not
working hard there they go to parties
they have lots of other things but they
are paddling madly they're studying
secretly so they will look smart one of
my Crusades is to get rid of duck
syndrome because it comes out of the
fixed mindset belief that you're only
smart if you don't have to apply effort
every year I teach a Freshman Seminar to
16 Stanford freshmen and I have them do
a paper on their hero and how their hero
got to be where he or she got to
originally many of them think oh these
were just supremely talented beings
geniuses or Naturals who floated
effortlessly to these great heights not
once has that been the case they see
that these people they admire worked
harder than anyone else
often encountered seemingly and survived
suitable setbacks and succeeded in
surrounding them I think that's much
more admirable than being born with
something that just propels you
somewhere and I think we should make
that the admirable thing throughout our
culture so in a fixed mindset it's not
just perfection but effortless
perfection good luck
third and finally in a fixed mindset
errors and setbacks are calamities hello
errors and setbacks are Clem it's never
too young actually to hear this
because as an aside and this is aimed at
you mom we published a study a few
months ago showing that parents praise
to their babies predict one to three
years of age predict the child's mindset
and desire for challenge
five years later mothers who gave their
babies process praise about the process
they're engaging in good effort good
trying good strategies had babies who
had more of a growth mindset and more
desire for challenge five years later so
none of this you're brilliant you're
great you're genius now I feel qualified
to intervene when I hear a mother in an
airport telling her baby what a genius
you are no no no
oh so third and final in a fixed mindset
errors are and setbacks are calamities
they are the surest sign of incompetence
or unworthiness and what we find is that
people in a fixed mindset run from their
errors or hide their errors in a study
with David Nussbaum we gave engineering
students three short engineering tests
tests we said or tests of engineering
aptitude they did really well on two of
the tests but poorly on the third and
then we said hey which one do you want
to take a tutorial in and then redo the
test and at the end we'll give you a
certificate with your score on this last
test on the certificate those were the
growth mindset overwhelmingly chose to
take a tutorial in the on the exam that
they didn't do so well in that makes
sense but those with a fixed mindset
overwhelmingly chose to take a DES to
Tory 'el in something they were already
perfect they didn't want to risk having
a less than or perfect score and
blazoned on our certificate you can see
how this fear of errors closes people
off to learning and growth do you want
to know what happens in the brain when
people encounter errors it depends on
your mindset Jason Moser and his
colleagues measured the electrical
impulses from the part of the brain that
deals with errors as people worked on a
task and occasionally made errors when
you look at the pictures of the brains
of people with a growth mindset while
they're making the errors that part of
the brain the anterior cingulate cortex
is red hot
they are detecting their error
processing the error and correcting it
detecting processing correcting they are
glomming onto it and extracting
everything they can from it but when we
looked when they looked at the brains of
people in a fixed mindset as they
encountered the errors nothing happened
that brain was a deep green cold they
did not process or correct the errors
they ran from the errors as quickly as
possible oh that didn't happen to me
next and again you can see how not
attending to your errors not processing
them Rob's you of valuable information
that you need to learn grow and succeed
no wonder because of what errors mean
errors are deeply diagnostic
their ability now wonder we find that
people students in a fixed mindset say
after poor score on an exam they
consider cheating next time the poor
score meant they weren't good at it they
don't like effort they don't believe in
effort cheating becomes a viable option
or in some studies we've found they lie
about a poor score when they have the
opportunity it's as though admitting
imperfection makes it real and that
imperfection in a fixed mindset is
permanent in my book mindset I write
write about the tragic cases of two
young people
Janet Cooke and Stephen glass whose
lives were completely derailed they were
both young journalists who skyrocketed
to the top but unfabulous Janet Cooke
actually won a Pulitzer Prize for her
Washington Post article about an
eight-year-old boy who was a drug addict
the boy did not exist and she was later
stripped of her prize Stephen glass was
the whiz kid of the New Republic
magazine he seemed to have stories and
sources that other reporters only
dreamed of the problem was he dreamt it
all up the sources didn't exist the
stories weren't true did Janet cook and
Stephen glass feel that admitting
ignorance would discredit them with
their colleagues did they feel they
should already be like the big
expert reporters before they did the
hard work of learning how Stephen glass
said we were the stars precocious stars
and that was what mattered the public
understands them as cheats and cheat
they did but I understand them as
talented young people who succumbed to
the pressures of a fixed mindset who
felt they had to be perfect there was a
saying in the 60s that went like this
the 1960s of becoming becoming is better
than being the fixed mindset doesn't
allow people the luxury of becoming they
already have to be and be perfect the
good news as we were told at the
beginning is that a growth mindset can
be taught and it can be taught at any
age it can be taught to little kids
and in fact parents tell me often I got
a an email from an executive that Apple
not long ago he said his four and a half
year old son was taking piano lessons
and was struggling through his practice
the good dad started marching over
whereupon the son turned around
said don't worry dad I have a growth
mindset many parents tell me their
three-year-olds will say good effort
mommy or good try daddy maybe you can
try another way my former student Jason
Flags is now doing studies with elderly
individuals showing that teaching a
growth mindset improves their memory
performance in our studies where we
teach a growth mindset we teach people
that every time they push out of their
comfort zone work on something really
hard and learn something new their
brains form new connections and over
time they can get smarter this is a
thrilling message we'll never forget the
one boy in one of our studies a teenage
boy in one of our workshops he was an
aide of our existence
he was always cutting up with his
friends being disruptive he seemed
uninterested in our pearls of wisdom but
when we started teaching the growth
mindset and how you can grow your brain
like a muscle he sat down shoot his
friends away and said you mean I don't
have to be dumb and he caught fire as
have many students learning the growth
mindset but the amazing thing is that it
completely learning this growth
I'm set and this completely transforms
the meaning of effort and difficulty in
a fixed mindset effort and difficulty
people say make you feel dumb
incompetent inadequate but in a growth
mindset we learn that when we're
struggling with effort and difficulty
that's when we're getting smarter that's
when the brain is forming new
connections and making us more competent
can you feel that difference I'm on a
worldwide crusade now to change our
value system away from effortless
success as the ultimate and toward
effortful success as the ultimate not
long ago someone from another country
said to me in your culture struggle is a
bad word I said you know you're right
rarely do you come home at the end of
the day and say honey I've had a
fabulous struggle now usually you're
crawling in the door dragging yourself
over the threshold may be in need of
some form of libation but why shouldn't
we Revere struggle it means we've worked
hard towards something we value why
shouldn't we sit around the dinner table
and say who had a fabulous struggle
today and each person goes around and
shares what they've struggled with what
are you going to struggle with tomorrow
that is the greatest gift that we can
give ourselves
and others that value system that says
struggle that's when you grow the
neurons struggle that's when you're
doing something important so instead of
praising each other when you do
something easily quickly without
mistakes no because that means hey if
you didn't do it quickly easily without
mistakes
you wouldn't be praiseworthy we should
say Oh easy that's a waste of time
something hard
now that's juicy that's something you
can sink your teeth into something you
can learn from something worthwhile I
fear that in our eagerness to instill
confidence in the younger generations
and in each other we're praising the
wrong things our work shows that
praising easy praising brilliance no
let's get that value system where
difficult things where you struggle make
mistakes flounder that's when it happens
that's the zone of getting smarter so
what about me am i still perfect no not
by a long shot I pursue high standards
but shouldn't we get rid of that word
perfect it has tormented so many
talented people and doomed them to
oblivion being a work in progress isn't
that better than perfect setting high
standards striving to learn working
struggling toward hard things we value
failing and bouncing back isn't that
better than
perfect can we find another word that's
better than perfect growth growth ISM
growth eNOS what is the highest
compliment were boy you have such
wonderful growth eNOS well okay so
that's a work in progress too but if you
can think of a good word all suggestions
are welcome I want to return one final
time to Pam Scott's survey of people
where she asked them am i a
perfectionist and one of them said the
thing that is really hard and really
amazing is giving up on being perfect
and beginning the work of becoming
myself I agree by giving up the idea of
perfection we can start a life long
wondrous ever rewarding journey to
becoming ourselves thank you
you